Hi my name is Jesse Goldhammer...
...and I'm the associate dean at UC Berkeley School of Information...
...with another Kantola learning minute.
Today Mike asks,...
"What's the truth about using the internet in my local coffee shop or at the airport?"
Well, the truth is that those public wi-fi networks are insecure.
Even if you're using a password to access them.
And the reason is that there may be others on that network...
...who may also be using that password...
...who can potentially get access to information on your computer...
...or can access information that your computer is sending elsewhere on the internet.
There are two things you can do to stay safe.
The first is when you're on the wi-fi network, the public wi-fi network,...
...don't access information that is sensitive.
So don't log on to your bank account to conduct the transaction.
The better solution is to use a virtual private network or VPN.
What that software does is it encrypts the data that moves from your computer...
...elsewhere on the internet so even if someone else is accessing it,...
...they won't be able to read it.
Thank you so much.